extreme weather events like these are
becoming more frequent fire seasons
growing longer and more intense as
produce 50% more rain than it otherwise
would happen in a non climate change
emergency right now it's not just
causing untold human suffering but also
ever-growing economic costs as the
losses pile up will insurers be able to
cope with the damage in 2017 hurricane
Harvey mudslides in Sierra Leone and
monsoon floods in South Asia all
contributed to the largest year on
record for insurance losses with payouts
totaling one hundred and forty four
billion dollars in America for example
between 1988 and 15 you had about five
events a year that each cost more than 1
billion dollars in damage since turn 16
it's been an average of 15 events like
this year
this leaves the insurance industry
uniquely exposed and having to pay out a
lot of money all at once insurers aren't
helped by the obsolete information they
rely on either they're funny hard to
predict when this happens because their
models are not really taking into
account climate change they look at
maybe 30 40 years of data and they
assume that the environment within this
data this period is pretty stable so
these models look at a world that
doesn't really exist anymore and it's no
surprise what's now happening to the
price of insurance so if you look at the
last quarter and premiums on property
insurance in America rose by 10 percent
in Australia New Zealand there was but
about 80 percents and at some points
premiums may simply become unaffordable
especially so as disasters regularly
happen in places where people can least
afford to pay
high premiums half of last year's losses
from natural disasters were uninsured
and in America eighty-five percent of
homeowners have no flood insurance even
though half of the population lives near
water increasing premiums might just
lead to even more people being left out
in the cold but there are some more
novel solutions so for example Lloyd's
of London as a policy that sends
southern euros per hectare to Spanish
early farmers as soon as temperatures
reach 36 degrees so these are very
simple solutions to put in place very
easy to implement and so quite cheap in
fact which is the main limitation rather
than compensate the farmers after their
losses are reported insurance companies
monitor a specific parameter such as
rainfall or temperature when this passes
an agreed threshold they pay out a lump
sum known as parametric insurance this
approach can help the insurance
companies cut costs and in turn bring
down premiums for the consumer but as
the climate crisis worsens the same
challenges are likely to re-emerge we
cannot expect insurers to save us from
climate change because the world
fundamentally cannot be insured against
climate change however many companies
already offer discounts to homeowners
who for example install metallic
shutters on the windows or food probe
doors but they could make a more drastic
step so a city on the coast wants to
build flood defences this will require a
lot of money but perhaps insures maybe
in cooperation with banks could offer
some financing for them to do that they
can help us design solutions or tech
measures that will limit losses and this
is really the crucial role they can play
[Music]
you
[Music]